well what's the speaker of the house
what's the purpose of the role it's it's
third in line for the presidency all
right they're they basically are the
highest position in Congress in in the
house and so they sent committees they
they decide when bills go to the floor
things like that is it they the one
person sets every committee I I don't
know exactly it's through the house
steering committee but the speaker
basically controls his appointment so by
extension the speaker yeah it makes
sense can the speaker overrule the point
committee is that what's called they can
they can change the rules of the session
of the Congress it's a very powerful
position in government yeah someone joke
someone joked that um the the the
concession for like Matt Gates and
bobert and all them they should tell
Kevin McCarthy new rule for the for for
the 118th Congress that Democrats don't
get to vote
you could make any like you can make up
weird rules I don't know how weird you
can get but uh like Papa John's for
dinner on Thursdays they could do that
kind of stuff I mean that'd be that'd be
cool